Kerry Lake filed numerous claims
they were dismissed by a lower court
Kerry Lake appealed and one very
important component one of the most
important made it through now the
corporate press is saying Kerry Lake
mostly loses appeal
if you're filing a lawsuit like this you
don't just say here's my one complaint
you get as many as you can and throw
them all out there scatter shot and then
see which ones stick and Kerry Lake got
one signature verification when the the
the the argument is uh not just in Kerry
Lake's case but in Trump as well the
argument is too many signatures got
accepted that should not have that many
of these probably didn't match but they
were letting them through anyway when
Kerry Lake sued they said this is a
procedure question and you should have
sued before the election well now the
Appellate Court a supreme court has said
no how would she Sue unless there was
something done that she can sue over go
back and redo this